a head coach of Notre Dame football who
this season is he her as you just heard
is undefeated after beating my alma
mater in week one and now going to the
Valhalla known as Yankee Stadium
although new Yankee Stadium to take on
none other than Chris Brockman's alma
mater the Syracuse Orange
he is Brian Kelly how are you coach
which I'm doing good thanks for having
me on the show of course come on you
know what it all comes down to it you
know I like talking to you
well we put that Michigan stuff away
plus it was early in the season we
played Michigan so it really doesn't
count right well let me see I'm looking
at the standings no accounts yeah it
counts it's the only sport you know
college football it seems like I grew up
in Boston right so it's a sports town
you know baseball football hockey you
know and head-to-head competition at the
end of the year they go well they won
the tiebreaker college football there's
no tiebreaker I guess if you play each
other well I mean when it all comes down
to it that's it it's the schedule and
head to head and that's why a lot of
folks think that if you should stumble
over the next two weeks that it doesn't
matter what Michigan does I mean do you
have that philosophy in your mind here
yeah I mean I think at the end of the
day it's it's so competitive that for us
we've always felt like you know you've
got to win every week and so our focus
has always been about taking care of
business each and every week and I don't
know that we've ever had a goal that hey
if we get one win maybe we can get in
it's you know you're playing for a
national championship no name we don't
have a conference to play for so it's
it's when every game you play well I to
me I think that's a benefit that you
don't have a conference to play for
that's an extra game where where you put
it all on the line for what right yeah
exactly I mean you know there's only one
thought process for us and that's to be
one of the four teams to get in and I
think you have to always think about you
know playing you know each and every
game as if it's a playoff game so I know
that's the way our guys feel about
playing Syracuse this weekend do you
feel any Ness
Ceri no I know you win you're in I get
it but do you still feel necessary to
potentially lobby the crew that picks
these Final Four in any way shape or
form no I don't think so
you know I think you know from our
perspective is that you know we can't
count on every year you know what the
other teams are going to be like I mean
we put our schedule together knowing
that we want to put together a
competitive national schedule every
single year and you know if you look at
our schedule down the down the road
every year you know you look at and go
out Florida State and you know you've
got Michigan and you've got USC and
Stanford that holds up you know - the
smell test relative to the kind of
schedule you're playing so we can't
really worry about that we've just got
to play them as we as we get them how is
your team any different from other than
obviously who's your starting
quarterback and then that week one where
you took on Michigan coach well I think
the running game - Dexter Williams as a
home run punch that we had lacked you
know at 200 yards rushing last week he's
gone for 200 on a couple occasions we
did not have him for the first four
weeks so I think those two and that then
I think you know we we really didn't
have any of those playmakers with any
maturity Miles Boykin was a not a
starter for us last year he's matured
chase Claypool Chris sink all of those
guys on the offensive side of the ball
were not starters for us last year and
they would shorten to now much more
veteran like in their presence on the
offense so we're gonna see Ian book and
he's healthy yeah yeah he's practiced
the last couple days and he'll be ready
to go okay what does he bring to your
team consistency and performance high
percentage store of the football runs
the offense very well just very very
efficient in the kind of offense and the
style of it so that we want to right now
Brendan we run a different style of
offense it's much more predicated on the
run game you know we ran for over 350
yards against Florida State last week
it's the ability to push the ball down
the field vertically it's an effective
offense but it's a different style of
offense than what
Ian's book is in there Notre Dame
Fighting Irish head coach Brian Kelly
here on the Rich Eisen show what
concerns you about Syracuse well they've
got a system in place now for over the
last three years that they haven't
changed and I think Dino Babers done a
great job of sticking with it hasn't
changed this went through two growing
pains seasons if you will at four and
eight and didn't listen to all the noise
stuck with it and and now these guys are
three years into a system that they
really runs very very well and they're
matured and you know the quarterback is
fearless
you know he'll he'll go out there and
make plays for defensively they've added
some veteran players that can get to the
pass to the quarterback they pass rush
very well and they're deserving of where
they are it's a good football team okay
let's get to the Yankee Stadium at all
yeah I'm gonna just gonna come straight
through you just already mentioned
you're from New England are you a Red
Sox fan going to Yankee Stadium Brian I
am I am but we already get the trophy so
it's really not an issue you know we've
already won there so this is really cool
so we're taking kind of a victory lap
but you put your team in pinstripes
though I mean you good with that I am
look I mean there are two great
franchises I mean you have to respect
you know the work that the both
franchises have done I mean I'm not
calling another name of franchise but
you know the Yankees franchise is iconic
the tradition of Notre Dame it matches
really well so I think this is a this
gonna be a great event
yeah the end locks interlocks with the D
in the same way that the end interlocks
at the lie for the Yankees right it's
more than that it's just you know it's a
great area for us in our alumni base and
and certainly for for Notre Dame
football to to pair up with the Yankee
tradition I just think it's great okay I
don't know I think you're just saying
that because you're just you know it's
business I understand that because you
just I mean you get your first chance
you had you took the swipe at the
Yankees with the Red Sox done no I was
just saying we've already got it you
know
so I don't
go right to tradition we don't have to
worry about
we won why we're at Yankee Stadium in
clinched the pennant okay so did you are
you pushing to maybe play a game at
Fenway we did yeah we did that a couple
years ago against Boston Boston College
enjoyed that the Green Monster the whole
thing just it doesn't get any better
when you're independent you get a chance
to do a lot of things it makes it
difficult in some areas but the ability
to play you know we played Navy out in
San Diego Chicago northwestern New York
we go to LA we're like a Broadway show
so you know look I'm not the type of guy
that normally tells successful coaches
such as yourself how to do your job but
maybe what you should do is take your
kids to Monument Park in in right field
there or wherever they've put it now
I've been in the Yankee Stadium now okay
and you go there and you show off all of
the 27 Championships that the Yankees
have had so that you could see what
sustained long success in baseball is
like you understand about what 27 is
compared to what was it four or five in
in Boston
coach Wow four or five in the past 12 12
15 years no you know we're we're
certainly going to take in the tradition
of what has been Yankee Stadium but
we're gonna remind them that this year's
the World Series champs are still
involved ok very good if you could
change college football playoff I know
we've kind of discussed it before but
now that you're sitting there at three
one of three undefeated teams or UCF
would raise their hand and say one of
four do you do you like it do you think
there should be more we had we had Mike
Leach on last week he he he went off
about a 64 team idea that he had coach
well that you could have a whole show
with Mike that's for sure you know I
think there's five you know there's five
power five you know when we talk about
power five conferences it just doesn't
for me the numbers don't seem to add up
always write it let's let's say the it
happens that Georgia wins right and and
now you've got two SEC schools and we're
gonna win out Notre Dame that's you know
an independent there's three you know
maybe there's only two of the power five
in the the BCS image that doesn't make
much sense to me that three of the other
power files are left out I think I think
sooner or later you're gonna want that
all of the the power fives get an
opportunity to be in this and to me I'm
not great in math that's why I got into
football coaching nice you would seem to
think eight would be the right number
but every time we bring that up
we're met with you know it's too many
and we've already decided on this but I
just don't see how this can sustain it
if you're only getting a couple of the
power five conferences into the BCS
Championship now it's obvious to me that
it would be beneficial to a team that
has one loss to have a conference
championship game to perhaps improve
their standing and get in by slaying a
Goliath you don't have that problem if
you're undefeated if you're undefeated
which is the issue for some of these
undefeated teams do you do you see
potentially you getting into a
conference and joining it and getting
giving up your independence at all you
know it's always asked of us and and I
just don't see that that right now
becomes a factor for us in terms of how
how it looks I mean you know the big 12
could play themselves out with a
conference championship because they
both have you know losses and they may
end up playing each other again the same
team so you just it's so cyclical with
the conference championships it's not a
guarantee so I think if we play a
competitive schedule like we have every
single year if we sit at the end of the
year 12 and ohm we don't get in there's
nothing that we can do about it maybe
we'll be like Central Florida and we'll
put up our own national championship
banner I mean I really think that where
we are a conference championship or a
conference doesn't do us any any better
coach really appreciate the time always
yeah good talking to you too right back
at you say hi to all 27 championships
and Yankee Stadium when you're down
there okay calculator heartache that's
at coach Bryant kill the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience